This is part two
of the FOM lecture
on special senses
and organs.
And so these are
senses and organs that
exist only in the
head and the neck.
We're going to
quickly cover the five
special senses in
the head and neck. So
these are senses that
should be familiar to
you. You use them
every day. And these
include the sense of
olfaction or smell,
vision,
taste or gustation,
hearing, and balance.
And we will not
cover these in a
big detail today.
you will have
another lecture that
will cover these
senses in much
greater detail.
We'll start off with
salivary glands. So
salivary glands
secrete saliva directly
into the oral cavity
through ducts. And so
you think there's only
one set of salivary
glands, but there are
actually three. So
we'll start with
parotid gland, which is
located anterior
to the ears in the
posterior cheek region,
which you can see here.
And it secretes a
lot of watery saliva
given the parasympathetic
innervation.
And then when you have a
sympathetic
innervation firing up,
then you have a
small amount of
viscous saliva
that gets produced.
Next up is submandibular
gland, which
is located just
below the inferior
margin of the
mandible. And the
secretions travel through
this submandibular
duct to get into
the oral cavity.
And finally you
have the sublingual
gland which is located
in the floor of
the mouth and the
secretions travel
superiorly through
just numerous small
ducts instead of
one central duct.
You also have a lacrimal
apparatus in the head
which is a system
responsible for crying. So
crying starts with
the lacrimal gland
producing tears and going
through the lacrimal
ducts, which will place
the tears onto the
surface of the eyes,
which then, as you blink,
gets washed
away immediately
into the canaliculi.
And those drain into
the lacrimal *** right
next to the nasal
cavity, and then drains
down through the nasal
lacrimal duct, and then
there's an opening
into the nasal cavity.
And this is why
when you cry, you
tend to sniffle
because you have the
tears going into
the nasal cavity.
And of course,
when this drainage
system gets blocked
by injury or
infection, then it
can lead to irritated
eyes since you
have accumulation
of tears on the
surface of the eye.
In addition to the
glands in the head, you
also have important
glands in the neck.
So these include the
thyroid, which is an
H-shaped gland that sits
in front or anterior
to the trachea. And
the function of the
thyroid is that it
takes up iodine from
food to produce growth
hormones. So these
include the T3 and T4
hormones. So they're
triiodothyronine and
thyroxine hormones.
And the production
is controlled
by the pituitary gland.
You also have the
parathyroid glands. You
have superior to
inferior sets, and
these sit within the
thyroid gland and
produces parathyroid
hormone, and it helps to
regulate calcium and
phosphorus levels
in the body and also
controlled by pteriotary
gland as well as
the hypothalamus.
Lastly, we have the
thymus gland, which
is active in
newborns and up until
adolescence. It
produces thymusin that
produces or promotes
differentiation and
maturation in T
lymphocyte precursors that
get transported from
the bone marrow.
And so you'll notice
in the cadavers in the
anatomy lab that
the thymus will look
probably like a blob of
adipose tissue because
they're not active in
mature individuals.
now the clinical
correlate related to these
glands specifically
the thyroid gland is
goiter so this happens
when there's an
*********** of the
thyroid gland and it's
presented externally as
a lump on the anterior
mid middle aspect
of the neck and this
is often due to iodine
deficiency so in
renaissance paintings
you can actually see
evidence of goiter in
some of the portraits
so this could be due
to hyperthyroidism so
obviously when you
have a larger thyroid
gland it could lead
to overproduction of
thyroid hormones but
this *********** of the
thyroid gland can
also be caused by
hypothyroidism because
the underproduction of
thyroid hormones will
lead to the swelling of
glands in order to
try to produce more
growth hormones and goiter
could cause breathing
and swallowing
difficulties or even
speech loss due to
the compression of the
trachea, larynx,
esophagus, and the current
laryngeal nerve, which
allows us to speak.